[Música]
nueva jornada de protestas contra el
golpe militar en mi animar las fuerzas
de seguridad abrieron fuego para
dispersar la manifestación en la ciudad
de mandalay mientras se desplegaron con
vehículos blindados en principales
ciudades que cortaron el internet una
vez más la respuesta lideran sanssouci
permanecerá detenida al menos hasta el
miércoles
por primera vez los partidos
separatistas de cataluña superan el
umbral del 50% en unas elecciones
parlamentarias y fortalece en su mayoría
el partido esquerra repúblicana dijo que
ha llegado el momento para negociar un
referéndum de independencia las
elecciones también estuvieron marcadas
por la llegada del partido
ultraderechista box al parlament
entraron en vigor las nuevas medidas
para frenar la propagación del hobbit 19
en reino unido desde hoy se requiere de
cuarentena obligatoria en hoteles para
los ciudadanos británicos e irlandeses y
los residentes que ingresen desde las
zonas de alto riesgo tenemos reportes
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france24 blanco un gusto
saludarlos aumenta la atención en
mianmar este lunes las fuerzas de
seguridad abrieron fuego para dispersar
las manifestaciones en la ciudad de
mandalay el despliegue de tanques en
varias ciudades ha despertado temores de
que el ejército esté planeando una nueva
ofensiva contra la oposición dos semanas
después del golpe de estado internet
volvió a ser suspendido y miles de
personas participaron unas protestas la
detención de la respuesta lideranza
succi fue extendida veamos el siguiente
informe
nuevas protestas en la ciudad más grande
de mianmar tras el despliegue de tanques
y tropas adicionales en las calles de
rangún y otros centros urbanos
importantes esto ha generado temores de
que el ejército esté planeando tomar
medidas enérgicas contra las
manifestaciones
mauro bogado tuve miedo anoche
pensábamos que nos dispararía como lo
hicieron en el pasado
el sábado el ejército se otorgó amplios
poderes para arrestar personas y
registrar propiedades privadas también
ha publicado enmiendas al código penal
destinadas a sofocar la disidencia
internet se ha restaurado después de que
se bloqueara el acceso durante la noche
del domingo una activista que deseo
permanecer en el anonimato dijo a france
24 que las personas temen ser detenidas
durante la noche
podemos ver muchos camiones y tanques
militares y algunos otros vehículos
blindados
wii
todos estamos traumatizados todos como
nación le tememos a la oscuridad y las
cosas pueden empeorar en cuestión de
wenzhou
aunque las manifestaciones han sido en
gran parte pacíficas
el domingo se realizaron disparos para
dispersar a las multitudes reunidas
frente a una planta de energía en el
estado norteño de kachin desde entonces
las embajadas occidentales han instado a
los generales a mostrar moderación han
pasado poco más de dos semanas desde que
los militares tomaron el poder
derrocando al gobierno democráticamente
elegido de anshan su chica su período de
detención por cargos de importación
ilegal de walkie talkies venció el lunes
pero se ha extendido hablamos con el
juez del distrito y nos dijeron que la
prisión preventiva se aplica hasta el 17
de febrero
es probable que esta medida entienda aún
más las tensiones entre los militares y
los manifestantes que han salido a las
calles por décimo día en otras noticias
las elecciones de cataluña se saldaron
con el empate de 33 escaños entre la
formación independentista esquerra
republicana y el partido socialista de
cataluña que no consiguió superar al
independentismo a pesar de tener un
mayor porcentaje de los votos la gran
sorpresa de estas elecciones fueron los
11 asientos que se llevó el partido de
ultraderecha box situándose como la
cuarta fuerza política durante la
primera vez que presenta su candidatura
en cataluña alba santana con los
detalles
tras una jornada electoral empañado por
la pandemia las elecciones catalanas se
saldaron con el empate entre el partido
socialista de cataluña y la formación
independentista esquerra repúblicana con
33 escaños cada uno la opción socialista
no logró superar al independentismo como
vaticinaban algunos sondeos a pesar de
ser el partido con más votos no obstante
el candidato salvador y ya calificó los
resultados como una victoria para su
partido la victoria clarísima del psc en
votos
esta noche tiene un significado para mí
muy claro el de pasar página y abrir una
nueva página en cataluña
una nueva página de cambio de cambiar
para reencontrarnos dije a todos ustedes
que si ustedes ponían los votos nosotros
pondríamos el cambio y por eso les
quiero anunciar esta noche que
presentaré y me presentaré a la
investidura presidente de la generalitat
la mayoría de los votos en conjunto han
ido para las formaciones
independentistas el partido junts per
cat quedó como la tercera fuerza con 32
escaños
el representante de esquerra repúblicana
pere aragonès aprovechó para mandar un
mensaje a toda europa sobre la necesidad
de un referéndum sit and talk
sentémonos y hablemos los catalanes han
hablado la hora de negociar un
referéndum de autodeterminación ha
llegado por favor impliquen se please
getting go
aunque es sin lugar a duda la gran
sorpresa de esta votación fueron los 11
asientos que logró box facción
ultraderechista situando así como la
cuarta fuerza política la primera vez
que presentaba su candidatura en
cataluña los resultados de estos
comicios son cruciales ya que definirán
si la autonomía es gobernada por un
partido independentista o no un tema que
divide a la sociedad catalana
con el 97 punto 44 por ciento de los
votos escrutados de las elecciones
legislativas en kosovo el partido
izquierdista y ultranacionalista
autodeterminación encabezado por alguien
kurt y triunfo con el 48 punto 19 por
ciento de los sufragios duplicando así
el apoyo que tenía en segundo lugar
quedó con el 17 punto 31 por ciento de
los votos el partido democrático surgido
de la guerrilla separatista que luchó
contra serbia a finales de 1990 y que
estuvo durante 20 años
ininterrumpidamente en el poder hasta
2019 a pesar de la victoria de
autodeterminación se espera una
complicada negociación para formar el
nuevo gobierno
y seguimos en américa latina' íbamos
hasta perú donde la canciller de ese
país renunció salpicada por el escándalo
de vacunación elizabeth astete admitió
que fue un grave error haberse vacunado
el 22 de enero antes que iniciara la
campaña de inmunización masiva en ese
país la tormenta política se desató el
jueves 11 de febrero cuando un diario
limeño publicó el que entonces
presidente martín vizcarra había sido
vacunado en octubre semanas antes de que
fuera destituido por el congreso en un
juicio político la emisión de aceite
sería la tercera en el gobierno de
francisco sagasti luego de que renunciar
a la ministra de salud pilar mazzetti y
el viceministro de salud pública luis
suárez
hoy lunes 15 de febrero entraron en
vigor las nuevas medidas para frenar la
propagación del cob y 19 en reino unido
entre ellas la cuarentena obligatoria en
hoteles para los ciudadanos británicos e
irlandeses y los residentes en ese
territorio que ingresen de las zonas de
alto riesgo nuestra corresponsal y se ha
pulido con todos los detalles de estas
nuevas medidas
esta medida es el escencia para países
de suramérica áfrica y portugal todos
los ciudadanos británicos irlandeses y
residentes legales tendrá que pagar
estas mil 750 libras esterlinas o un
poco más de dos mil cuatrocientos
dólares por diez días de estadía en
estos hoteles seleccionados por el
gobierno para hacer las cuarentenas este
costo incluye además dos pruebas el
coronavirus y por supuesto alimentación
los primeros ciudadanos que fueron
llevados a estos hoteles para cuarentena
llegaron esta mañana al aeropuerto
internacional de heathrow el principal
de londres y uno de los más grandes de
europa la población que ha tenido que
iniciar esta cuarentena se ha quejado
por los altos precios y entretanto las
directivas del aeropuerto han dicho que
las personas que vengan de estos países
pueden experimentar cancelaciones de
vuelos o largas filas de más de cinco
horas en el aeropuerto ahora que el
reino unido ha cumplido su meta de
vacunar
15 millones de personas dar la primera
dosis de la vacuna a esta población la
más vulnerable y a los trabajadores del
sistema nacional de salud el gobierno
empieza a revisar las cifras para
levantar poco a poco este tercer
confinamiento en que está inglaterra
desde los primeros días de enero la
prioridad será volver a las escuelas a
partir posiblemente del 8 de marzo está
hoja de ruta de cómo se relajara un poco
el confinamiento será anunciado por el
primer ministro del próximo 22 de marzo
austral y nueva zelanda recibieron este
lunes sus primeras dosis de la vacuna de
facer ambos países prevén iniciar lo
antes posible sus campañas de
inoculación las ciudades de más bonjour
clan se encuentran en confinamiento
debido a la aparición de nuevos casos de
contagio veamos el siguiente informe de
matías arabes
el águila ha aterrizado fueron las
palabras que eligió el ministro de salud
australiano al anunciar la llegada al
país del primer lote de vacunas más de
142.000 dosis del fármaco desarrollado
por facer han llegado al aeropuerto de
sídney
y eso significa que vamos a liberar
después de que todos esos procesos se
hayan completado
entonces aproximadamente 80 mil dosis
para las primeras vacunas que comenzarán
en australia el lunes 22 de febrero
schueri se kent el cb los trabajadores
de la salud y personal de asistencia a
personas de la tercera edad estarán
entre los primeros en ser vacunados
australia de 25 millones de habitantes
se vio obligado a imponer un nuevo
confinamiento en melbourne para contener
la circulación de la variante británica
en nueva zelanda también llegaron este
lunes las primeras 60.000 dosis de facer
en el caso del país vecino la estrategia
es de empezar con los trabajadores de
las fronteras a partir del sábado todas
las garantías de control de calidad
tienen que ser completadas antes de que
las vacunas sean enviadas
el dow clan de la presencia de la
variante de tres miembros de una familia
llevó a casi dos millones de residentes
a un confinamiento de tres días desde el
domingo beneficiados por su remota e
insular ubicación geográfica australia
con menos de mil muertes y nueva zelanda
con apenas 25 hacen parte de los países
que mejor han manejado la pandemia
al menos un muerto y un herido en una
multitudinaria manifestación en haití
para exigir la renuncia del presidente
yo en el mois la protesta fue pacífica
pero hubo enfrentamientos entre
manifestantes y la policía que utilizó
gases lacrimógenos y balas de goma un
reciente informe de la onu denunció que
la violencia de bandas ha suelto ha sido
creciente en las manifestaciones de los
últimos años en las que intervienen con
el fin de sembrar el caos
nuevos peligros para el futuro el
acuerdo nuclear alcanzado con irán en
2015 y un desafío para la administración
de job aid en la república islámica
informó este lunes que procederá a
limitar sus inspecciones del organismo
internacional para la energía atómica a
partir de la próxima semana si no se
levantan las acciones estadounidenses a
los sectores petroleros y bancarios de
irán la fecha límite es el 21 de febrero
teherán ha venido dando marcha atrás en
sus compromisos después de que el ex
presidente de donald trump retirar a
eeuu del acuerdo en el año 2018
y por primera vez en 102 años río de
janeiro se ha quedado sin los
tradicionales festejos del carnaval por
causa del coronavirus con el sambódromo
cerrado y las calles vacías son muchos
los que han optado por celebrar el
carnaval en familia es el caso de
algunos bate bola
son los grupos de clowns que desfilan
con ropas suntuosas en los barrios
periféricos de la ciudad y golpean
contra el suelo una pelota que provoca
un fuerte estruendo poco conocido fuera
de brasil los bateo la representan el
carnaval más popular y auténtico el
informes de valeria saccone y louis
roulet
el bate bola encarna la cultura de los
suburbios
cada año es el grupo carnavalesco
desfile en campo grande el barrio más
populoso del río de janeiro y también el
más castigado por el coronavirus todo
empieza en este taller meses antes del
carnaval la confección de los disfraces
es un trabajo artesanal realizado con
esmero y cariño
alguien si pinta pintamos primero los
colores escogidos del dibujo que está
hecho en el ordenador y después
colocamos la purpurina del mismo color
preferimos hacer nuestro traje a mano
porque queda más trabajado y tiene un
aspecto mejor
el vate bona es como una pequeña escuela
de samba todos los años se estrena un
tema una canción y una ropa diferente
el ideal es la alegría del barrio tanto
que cada barrio tiene su propio estilo
de bate bola
ay el bate moral gigante el de cappa el
de botas el bate bola en río de janeiro
representa el carnaval callejero
de la pandemia robo el carnaval a los
cariocas
[Aplausos]
piscina y asado son un pequeño consuelo
pero familia no se resigna su bate bola
saldrá aunque inversión reducida
hicimos unos disfraces más simples y
festejamos en un local privado para que
la policía no decomisen nuestros
disfraces además sería errado desfilar
la bola es el emblema de este personaje
hace tiempo que el plástico reemplazó
las tradicionales vejigas de buey pero
el ruido sigue potente
otros grupos de bate bola resolvieron
arriesgarse a pesar del veto municipal
en un impulso de última hora devolvieron
a las calles la magia del carnaval en un
desfile corto y clandestino
de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo en france 24 continúe con
nosotros para más actualizaciones de
noticias buen día y hasta pronto
[Música]
france24 en español sigue creciendo
desde